[Music]
winter is here and the world around us
seems to pause fields are blanketed in
snow plants stand still and everything
seems Frozen in time but for Farmers the
season doesn't stop it transforms into a
new kind of opportunity cold weather
farming may feel intimidating but with
the right mindset and strategies it can
be a season of incredible
success welcome to this guide on how to
farm successfully in cold weather
whether you're just starting or have
years of experience there's something
valuable here for everyone together
we'll dive into proven tips - tested
strategies and insightful techniques to
help you make the most of this unique
farming
season so let's get started and learn
how to embrace the cold work with nature
and grow in ways that you never thought
possible before before the snow even
Falls the work begins cold weather
farming is all about preparation you
have to plan ahead and the first step is
choosing the right crops while some
plants Wither in the frost others like
kale cabbage and spinach thrive in the
chill these hearty vegetables are
perfect for winter not only surviving
but often becoming sweeter and more
flavorful in cold
temperatures but it's not just about
what you plant it's about how you care
for for the soil before the freeze
adding organic matter like compost or
planting cover crops can significantly
improve your soil Health ensuring that
your crops have the nutrients they need
when it's time to
grow now soil preparation is essential
healthy well-balanced soil helps hold
moisture and temperature better ensuring
your plant stay protected during extreme
cold and before it's too late take the
time to protect your soil by adding
cover crops or mulch these act as
natural insulators for your soil keeping
it warm and healthy through the winter
[Music]
months another crucial step protective
structures while green houses and high
tunnels may seem like expensive
Investments they can dramatically extend
your growing season for smaller setups
row covers and frost cloths work Wonders
by trapping heat while allowing light to
reach your plants these tools not only
protect against Frost but can also
Shield crops from harsh
winds when it comes to cold weather
farming timing is everything you must
plant early enough to give your crops a
fighting chance before the first Frost
for most crops the ideal planting time
is at least 6 to 8 weeks before the last
expected frost date in your area and
remember knowing your local Frost dates
is key use online tools or Farmers
almanacs to help determine when it's
safe to
[Music]
plant once you've chosen your crops and
know your timing it's all about planting
smart for example cold hearty greens
like arugula and chard should be planted
early enough that they can mature by the
time the coldest months hit and remember
Frost hearty crops often take a little
longer to grow than others so give them
that extra space to
[Music]
thrive once the shops are in it's time
for the real magic protection mulch row
covers Frost blankets these are your new
best friends even though the sun is weak
during winter your plants still need
light and row covers allow them to bask
in those few precious hours of sunlight
while keeping them insulated from the
chill think of row covers as Tiny green
houses for your plants these lightweight
materials trap warmth reduce wind damage
and provide protection from frost all
while still allowing plants to breathe
it's like giving your crops their own
little Cozy home now let's talk mulch
this simple yet powerful technique acts
like a giant insulator keeping your
plant roots safe from freezing
temperatures spread a thick layer of
straw leaves or even wood chips around
your plants to provide this extra layer
of warmth
[Music]
for those of you with livestock winter
care is just as important animals are
especially vulnerable during the colder
months and ensuring their comfort is
crucial start by offering well-insulated
shelters to protect them from biting
winds in the
snow consider increasing their calorie
intake to help them stay warm and
healthy in the winter animals need more
energy to regulate their body heat so
higher fat feed is a great
option water can freeze quickly in cold
weather
and no one wants to be hauling buckets
of water in freezing temperatures
install heated water trops to ensure
your livestock always have access to
Fresh unfrozen
water let's not forget about your farm
equipment the colder months can be tough
on Machinery so it's vital to winterize
everything before the cold really sets
in clean and oil your tools check your
equipment for wear and tear and store
Machinery in a warm dry place to protect
it from the elements
take time to inspect tractors plows and
any other equipment you rely on this
simple maintenance will save you time
and frustration when the work starts
piling
[Music]
up winter farming isn't just about
strategy it's about mindset the cold
months can be tough on Farmers mentally
and emotionally but they're also a time
of reflection growth and resilience
Embrace The Quiet Moments enjoy the
beauty of winter and don't forget to
take care of yourself
too even when the frost sets in and the
winds howl remember that you are part of
something much larger farming in winter
is a journey that builds patience and
grit it's not easy but the rewards are
rich so are you ready to embrace the
cold and start your own winter farming
success story with the right preparation
tools and mindset you can turn winter
into your most productive season yet
keep these tips in mind and don't be
afraid to experiment and adapt to your
unique
conditions don't forget to hit that
subscribe button share your thoughts and
questions in the comments below and
let's keep the farming conversation
going thanks for watching and stay warm
stay inspired and keep growing
[Music]